most important thing is hier kannst du
ihn cdu will er der vater des freestyler
smasher gasser der bei den olympischen
winterspielen in pyeong chang um
medaillen kämpfen das wichtigste sei
dass sein sohn jetzt dabei sei und
seinen traum leben können der vater des
sportlers und seine partnerin sind ein
jahr lang parat um die ganze welt
getourt um pünktlich zu olympia in
südkorea einzutreffen
rund 17.000 km reiseweg liegt hinter ihm
we move too es ist bewegend nach der
ganzen zeit hier anzukommen und zu sehen
wie mein sohn auf uns wartet mir fehlten
einfach die worte
die worte fehlen einem auch wenn man
sich anschaut wo die beiden radfahrer
auf ihrer reise überall waren 20 länder
haben die olympiatouristen nach eigenen
angaben durchfahren von der schweiz bis
nach südkorea dabei auch schwierige
etappen durch das gebirge und durch
unwegsames gelände
ein jahr lang hatten vater und sohn nur
über telefon und whatsapp kontakt nun
gab es das wiedersehen bei olympia für
seinen sohn hat der marathon radfahrer
eine klare botschaft
michael schär macht das beste was zu
geben kannst lebe deinen traum und höre
nicht auf leute die dir sagen was du zu
tun hast und was gut und schlecht ist
was immer du tust verfolge nur deinen
traum
[Musik]
auch die fahrradtour so noch ein stück
weiter gehen ist das paar weiter nach
japan fliegen wird